coming up on Star Talk we speak with my
friend and colleague Shields she's an
associate professor of astronomy
specializing in astrobiology at UC
Irvine and we talk about the search for
life on planets that are already known
to exist in orbit around their host
Stars we're going to learn what M stars
are we're going to find out what the
color of the star has to do with what
life might be like on a planet's surface
that orbits it and we'll also take
questions Cosmic queries from our
patreon members all that and more coming
right up
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist I
got Chuck nice with me Chuck yes
do it again this is the universe is
non-stop that's right and it's then it
is
it really yes it does it I mean
seriously can we say with certitude that
the Universe does not stop I mean if
there's anything in the universe that
doesn't stop it's the universe itself
there you go bam okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna see your statement
and raise your entropy so um
today we're talking about life on other
planets yes other planets and we're
bringing in a friend and colleague our
Mawa Shields thank you so much Neil I'm
excited to be here so she's an
astrophysicist and more specifically an
astrobiologist which is kind of a New
Field New in the last few decades I'm
old enough to call that new also on the
landscape of science communication she's
there and she's a force she's an
associate professor in the department of
physics and astronomy at UC Irvine and
founder of Rising Star Girls a program
dedicated to helping girls cover the
universe what I know also also a trained
actor what no wait a minute I know I
know wait I'm but I'm not done okay
until I'm done all right now she's got a
new book out okay now you can react what
and she's got a new book life on other
planets A Memoir of finding my place in
the universe
whoa oh my Lord welcome back to Star
tour I think we've had you on before you
have thank you it's wonderful to be back
last time we were talking about
terraforming Mars and now we get to talk
about more life on other planets places
where there actually could be life
although maybe Mars I don't know yeah
plus I want to get to the bottom of what
it means to have a book Total life on
other planets and now you call it a
memoir Chuck I think she's an alien okay
that's what I'm saying
how was the trip
I have a lot to share I have a lot of
information now
yeah so
um uh we'll get to your book a little
later but let me just just can you
update us on where are we in the search
for life in the universe because you you
focus on the habitability of exoplanets
and in multi-planet systems what climate
might be on those planets so what what
are you doing when you go to work each
day yes so my team's work starts after
the planets have actually been found so
it's hard enough as you know to find a
planet around another star although we
are going like gangbusters we're
approaching 6 000 planets that's right
yeah and that's in the that's the
tiniest fraction of our own Galaxy never
mind the fact that we have a hundred
billion plus galaxies in this universe
right but yeah we've got close to 6 000
now that we've found and so but we don't
really know anything about how habitable
they might be whether they might have
water on their surfaces which is what we
Define as habitable because we know all
life on earth needs water everything
from the tallest largest elephant to the
smallest teeniest microbe needs water
would you just confess that you're
completely biased because you're not
just looking for life you're looking for
Earth life that is true that is true and
this is why I want you to fess up yes
thank you show your cards okay very true
uh-huh and this is why the the field of
astrobiology is so important because
there are astrobiologists like me who
are looking for planets that might be
warm enough for liquid water on the
surface but not too warm
and they're also astrobiologists whose
job it is to ask the question what about
life as we do not know it what about
non-earth-like life could could life use
something else besides water or
something else besides carbon as in its
backbone so they're that's really
important we can't be so Earth focused
that we miss discovering life because of
that so it's true
because I've seen some missions they're
looking for Earth's like planets around
sun like stars you can't get more sort
of bias than that it seems true true and
some like stars are not the majority of
the stars in our galaxy the majority of
our the stars in our galaxy are actually
much cooler smaller and redder than the
Sun
so well that sounds to me like we should
be looking there
M so we're a G Star son is a G Star yeah
so what
ob-a-f-g-k-m so m is like the coldest
star category we have so why would you
think it's pretty cool we know of some
even cooler ones now like L's and T's
but then there's been some controversy
are those really stars are we getting so
cool that we're in the like brown dwarf
regime but uh and just to be clear when
an emphasis refers to a cool start we're
talking a few thousand degrees still
here it's still really hot not not
Robert Downey still be incinerated
yeah it's all relatives so how do you
modify your search for life around an M
dwarf star yeah you know it's not as
warm as the Sun so what happens to the
habitable zone and other sort of the
properties that you're seeing right so
if we you want to look for a planet that
could be what we call it this habitable
zone or the Goldilocks zone because it's
not too close to its star not too far
away so it's not too hot not too cold
we have to look much closer to an M Star
than we would to around a sun-like star
in the same way that if you're you know
say you're at on the beach and you're
crowding around a little campfire you're
gonna have to stand much closer to that
campfire to get the same amount of heat
as you would if that campfire was a
bonfire at the same principle exists
when we talk about these cool Stars
versus the hotter Stars so we're really
just redraws your habitable zone yeah so
it smushes it closer up and there's some
interesting things that can happen when
a planet is orbiting that close into its
Star right there's forces at work
there's Tides the planet pushes on the
star the star pushes on the planet and
the planet's rotation period can get
slowed down and maybe even to the
extreme case where there's one permanent
dayside and the other side it's always
night and we call that situation
synchronous rotation it's like this
extreme case of title locking and it's
literally always day on the day side
always night on the night side and and I
can't be good for life it people have
thought that it would be but if you want
to be bad right yeah
and then like a cookie too just have
like a work side of the planet and a
party side of the planet oh yeah I like
it
you don't wait for night to come yeah
you can go tonight go tonight all right
it's like yo what you doing later yo I'm
going over the night bro we're going we
gonna chop it up crazy like
get off
so that's that has been a big concern
however fresh off the presses my team
actually has some new work that shows
that you could have life
along the Terminator
the dividing line between the day and
the night side that's what we call the
Terminator so so and now so temperature
wise if it's always night and you're
just never facing anything
that that would be like a super cold
part of the planet right right and then
if they always date time that was super
hot collapse right so there's got to be
a spot
that's just right right yeah okay and
that you know and it's funny because
just right spot you call the Terminator
right so much more much more amenable
much more neutral than our our
pop fiction Schwarzenegger Terminator
right but I can't help I cannot help we
coined this term Terminator habitable
and that's the name of our paper and
like you're so definitely collectible
it's like a warm bath
so so before we continue let me if if I
may I will give a a brief tutorial on
how Stars got the letter classifications
oh you go back 120 years we're getting
data on stars that are not just pictures
of them but Spectra and we don't know
what Spectra are yet because quantum
physics wasn't yet discovered but we
knew some Spectra looked like others and
you could put them on a Continuum and
you can that transition from one kind of
spectrum to another
and so we did that and we letter them a
b c d e f g h i gate Elemental P okay
then quantum physics came around and we
said yo
they're reasons why the Spectra looked
this way and it's not what you're
thinking and it had to do with the
temperature of the star
and it turns out these features can
duplicate between being too cool to have
a feature and too warm to have that same
feature by the time we shuffled these
letters into a temperature sequence a b
c d e f g became o b a f g k m
and why didn't we just re-letter them
which I think we should have at the time
uh yeah but we did okay so we have this
article could have gone with numbers
pretty simple yeah because now we don't
confuse astronomy students the world
over year after year forever and ever
and ever every year and B stars are next
hearted it will be a g we're G star and
then each category is split into 10
other subcategories okay zero through
nine so we are a g two okay Arabic
numeral two okay and we divided them by
what's called Luminosity class like how
big are you and so we have classes one
through five or four or three yeah five
and so we are G Roman numeral two
I've got G Arabic numeral two Roman
numeral five
can you tell that to a natural physicist
they know exactly what kind of star
you're talking about
right that's what it is sounds like
something that rappers fly to their next
concert in
that's right
yeah d25 baby all right so tell me what
you what did you need to do to model a
Terminator habitability like what what
kind of calculations were necessary
there yes and I have to give a shout out
to my postdoc uh Anna Lobo who's
spearheaded this work and you know we
had to ask that question as I write in
the book that having this question could
these planets even exist it's the first
place to start for any scientists
curious person you know before you
invent life on a planet we're not sure
that kind of planet exists actually
exist and
the first thing we had to do we're using
models climate models that are normally
used to predict the climate on Earth so
they're the mod the same models that
have been used to predict the effects of
climate change into the 2100s the reason
why we know that climate change is real
and that it's going to continue unless
we do something is in part because we're
using these models to forecast those
effects but what we're doing and these
models so all you have to do is change
some of the they probably have none but
you can turn that's right for everything
else because the physics would just be
the physics but the rotation Ray and the
and this the the sun's energy entering
right these are knobs right these are
knobs that we can turn I didn't know
these are general climate models they're
fascinating that's right so we are
changing the spectrum of the host Star
right how it's how it's energy its light
is distributed across the whole spectrum
is going to be different depending on
the temperature of the star the type of
star we're changing how the shape of its
orbit how much is and it's at how much
atmosphere like what its atmospheric
composition is because we don't know
those things for earth-sized planets we
have no information about the type of
atmospheres they might have
or their surfaces and understanding the
effects on climate of different types of
atmospheres is going to help us
understand which of these nearly 6 000
planets we want to prioritize and look
at with you know the next large
generation telescopes to find out if
there really is life there
so this is a beautiful example of the
cross-pollination between two otherwise
very different disciplines
yes you go into climate science folks
they don't care about exoplanets they
didn't care about Earth right I know and
I'm on a personal crusade to to change
that because it's true like this is It's
So interdisciplinary we're using
atmospheric science climate science
astronomy geology in some cases
glaciology because I'm all about ice and
different types of ices and because
different types of ices interact with
different types of light depending on
the type of ice there's more than just
water ice we're looking at CO2 ice
um so different ice would reflect their
sunlight differently differently other
kinds of surfaces and it would change
how much energy enters the system
right okay exactly right
how does all this fold into this this
book that you just wrote
I'm so excited for this book this has
been a dream of mine for a long time and
as you know I have I was astronomer then
I trained I changed and studied acting
and then I came back and finished my PhD
and became a professional astronomer and
a professor and for the longest time I
was trying to reconcile these two things
that I loved acting and astronomy and I
thought that they couldn't co-exist I
thought I had to choose
and when I would share with people those
two loves I got a lot of like what this
is so strange why how and I you know I
think I internalized that and tried to
you know figure it out
and it was funny because when I stopped
figuring it out these incredible
Miracles got to happen where I saw how
they can really coexist like hosting a
science TV show which I could never have
planned on my own eventually going back
to grad school in part because of your
suggestion and you know being put in
touch with you and your mentorship and
also I had applied to the astronaut
candidate program and had not made had
not reached the next level it was like
everything was saying go back get your
PhD and I finally became willing to
listen and so the book really is about
that whole journey it's about why I fell
in love with the Stars and this and the
night sky and why I fell in love with
acting and this whole Edge that I
carried
for a long time of like feeling like I
was an astronomer or a scientist around
actors feeling like I was an actor
around scientists and eventually coming
into full acceptance of this
non-traditional background that I had
and how it could really make me a better
scientist and a better Communicator
because of it
um it's about the whole journey first of
all that's uh that's a beautiful what
you just said because it's a it's a
Reconciliation of self which I think is
always a good friend wonderful wonderful
that anyone has ever you could be you
could be a counselor you could be like a
therapist yeah if you want to mess up
your life
um
okay
so I think if if you're in if you have
these loves uh you know I I had I had
two heads so secondary Pathways but none
as significant in my life as your acting
was but I just did little things I
doodled and I liked calligraphy when I
should have been doing other things but
now when I sign my books I use a
holographic pen and the people receive
the book they appreciated that much it
was little things like that you find a
way to fold it in your life in the lives
of others are much more enriched so I'm
so glad that you pursued what you love
rather than what people thought you
should be doing
thank you I I have to say I still
remember and you're gonna find out you
you probably read parts of it already
but if not you'll see later like you're
in the book okay
am I in the book
you're gonna have to read it to find out
and you're in the book everybody
a lot of people are in the book but like
I write about that moment when you know
I first met you in person at the Double
A S the the American Astronomical
Society that's our professional uh
conference for for those who don't know
what double a s means and
we sat you know on some umbrella chairs
or whatever and people were walking by
like is that
is that who we think it is is that Neil
deGrasse Tyson and you know and and you
were just there and I think I like
started to cry at one point because I
you know we'd been talking about my
background and how I had you know I had
there were ups and downs I had struggled
academically because my head was not in
the place like my my heart and my head
were not in the same place you know you
know it's funny because I cried when I
met Neil too
stop that but that's because he was
standing on my foot the whole time
and he's a big guy I'm telling you he's
a large man it was not pleasant
wait I almost plus it didn't help
matters that you also married an actor
isn't that right for I remember
correctly is that correct I did yes and
he is 100 actor he doesn't have the like
yeah my actor scientist
he's 100 actor although he does enjoy
those like Doomsday Nat Geo shows or
like
but what I'm saying is that that would
have been a force that would have been
supportive of your acting correct and I
presume absolutely we met and act in
grad school he was my classmate oh okay
so at UCLA becoming a real actor she
said acting grad yes okay
yeah I that's that's the real stuff okay
yeah that's why you're just like you
know how people say well I'm going to be
an actor and they're like well you're
never going to get a job if when you say
I'm going to act in grad school they'll
be like oh you're getting a job
that's what we hoped and expected that
wasn't always the case but yes like we I
wanted to study it in the same way that
I studied astronomy I you know and and
and that was so much fun you know after
so I had left the PHD program that I was
struggling academically in and I had an
old white male Professor tell me to
consider other career options and you
know and I internalized that and
um and left and you know when I got to
act in grad school it was like I was
I was like I was free I felt so light
they but it wasn't like it was easier
compared to astronomy grad school it was
harder in a different way
um and I write about this it was like it
didn't it wasn't necessarily about the
brain cells working overtime it was
about dredging up my emotions and
feelings and childhood experiences and
like bringing it all up you know that I
needed to use it to embody summoning it
on commands summoning it on command yeah
it's got to be real it's got to be real
yeah so you Stitch this you made a
tapestry of your life with your
professional Ambitions in this book so
it's part Memoir part part uh advice
column is that is that fair yeah there's
a little bit of there's certainly it's
all spoken for the most part in the
first person like this is what I did
this is what helped me make my life
better and reconcile these different
parts of myself
um and I hope that I'm writing it for
the people that have that question of
like is it too late there's that part of
me that I never could you know bring up
into my life and and but it's always
been there like I say in the book it's
when you leave a dream behind it it
never dies it's like sitting on the side
of the road and eventually it'll catch
up and that's what happened for me you
know and the whole the message of the
book is that it's not too late and that
if there's no role model that's doing
what you want to do you can be your own
role model yeah yeah you know
um and in fact if you always needed a
role model you would only ever do things
that other people did before you but
sometimes you have to trailblaze and
like you just said if you become your
own model uh that's harder of course and
you got to figure things out on the fly
but uh if and when you succeed then
people say of course that's what I
always wanted to do those who come
behind you so just congratulations on
that thank you fantastic well Chuck
let's get to some queries all right why
not especially tuned for this visit
absolutely uh uh uh these are questions
from our patreon members patreon patrons
who yes for a paltry uh
um almost
insignificant five dollars a month this
is Mike Parker and Mike Parker says
hello Dr Shields Mike Parker here from
Richmond Virginia if life does exist in
our solar system which planet or Moon do
you think offers the most promising
location I love it in fact give me the
top three cases in order oh my gosh okay
um this is a fantastic question thank
you for asking it
Europa which is Jupiter moon of Jupiter
would be my top even though there's a
lot of Buzz right now around Saturn's
moon Enceladus which would be my number
two the next one
um Saturn's moon and celtus has geysers
geysers of liquid water that are
shooting out from its South Pole and
there was everything you can't argue
with geysers and apparently all of the
basic elements of Life are are there
um
geysers lead to geezers
Chuck I don't think that's how language
works okay
and then the third one give me a third
one
I mean I
I'm skeptical about Mars but Mark that's
under under surface Mars there might be
some liquid water in aquifers yeah I'll
be your third your third daughter I was
I was about to say that and then but I'm
skeptical but yes or it could be Mars
might have fossilized life okay so the
life was there it's no longer there but
that still counts because I would hear
it say here if we could prove that it
was there it still counts as life
because it was there true yeah and we
have so much and there's so much
evidence of liquid water on the surface
at what some point at one point yeah oh
yeah right right excellent excellent
question there nice keep it going Chuck
Mike Parker way to go all right here we
go this is uh Sherry
uh carisu and Sherry Caruso says hello
Dr Shields do the ideal conditions for
life on extrasolar planets depend on the
star itself or are the requirements the
same no matter what also thank you thank
you for Rising Star Girls I am
registering my niece you are an
inspiration Sherry from San Diego Thank
you so much Jerry for asking that
question and can't wait to see your
niece in Rising Star Girls workshops
coming up soon so
Rising Star Girls hosts summer we we
host annual virtual workshops during the
summer for middle school girls of color
and that means ages 10 to 14 or 15
roughly oh wow no one has turned away
and they're virtual so we have no matter
where you are that participate from all
over the country and we even have girls
participate from from other countries
too and we're we're ramping up to do
even more we also host educator webinars
where we we show Educators how to use
the activities in our handbook with
girls in their own communities all over
the world
um so and and back to your question
the ingredient we the primary
ingredients for life are
liquid water or a liquid which on our
planet is water and as we know we can't
just look for water but that's like
that's our first order thing we're
looking for some liquid that that life
can use to make its uh the stuff it
needs to carry out its chemical
processes and reactions
some kind of energy source whether it's
the sun the star or chemical energy like
life that lives in the deep ocean around
these hydrothermal vents has no access
to sunlight and yet there's life there
so it's using the chemistry of rocks and
heat from from the the core of the earth
and I add there that when I was taught
biology it was only assumed that life
could Thrive it was assumed that life
could only use sunlight because we
hadn't discovered the life at the bottom
of the ocean yet so they had to broaden
the definition nothing like depends on
the Sun but life depends on an energy
source so I like this that that's now a
folded into that definition okay so keep
going yeah thank you and then the last
one is
the basic building blocks of life like
some and some kind of environment for
life to to make its you know to carry
out its metabolic processes and to use
so we think of this like it needs sulfur
or phosphorus or oxygen or nitrogen or
carbon these are like the basic Elements
of Life
so the organic chemistry yeah the
Organics Organics energy source and
liquid
um so all of those things are what we
look for when we're looking for a planet
that could be habitable and for what I
the part that I am really focused on is
where could the climate be suitable for
water to not freeze not evaporate away
but to stay in in liquid form somewhere
on that surface and so this can be
affected by the type of star as you
bring up in your question because this
starlight can be different depending on
the temperature of the star how that
Starlight interacts with the surface of
the planet the various atmospheric
molecules
on that planet that can influence the
planet's climate so it does depend on
the star
um but those three ingredients are the
main ingredients that we think any kind
of
Planet would need to host life to keep
life going for you know now you just
made me think of a question that I've if
it's a dumb question just let me know uh
there are no dumb questions that that is
not true you're not you have not heard
me ask questions when people say there's
no dumb questions I'm like just wait
okay so are are there different stars
that give off different colors and can
look like our star is white are there
different stars that give off different
colors and can those different colors
actually affect the development of light
I mean of life
that is the complete opposite of a dumb
question that is a fantastic question so
yeah I'm not going to believe anything
you say now
okay it's not a tough question it's just
popping my head so when it just pops in
my head I'm like maybe that's a dumbass
question never never so yes
different stars have different colors
and if you if you are fortunate enough
to live someplace where you don't have a
lot of light pollution if you go out on
your porch or your stoop and look up
you'll see this you'll see this in
action that all of the stars don't all
look the same some of them look white
some of them look yellow some look a
little orange or a little red and if
they're twinkling that's a pretty good
bet that that's a star if it if it's uh
not twinkling then you can be more
convinced that it's a planet there's a
lot more stuff between us and a star
than there is between us and a planet in
our own solar system and so there's a
lot more atmospheric Distortion
Distortion and turbulence and that's
what we see as twinkling but anyway yes
the colors
the colors are real and that has to do
with the temperature of the star and how
much light it's emitting
um and that that light again that's
gonna if if there's a planet around that
star and just about every star in our
galaxy has a planet around it it may not
be in the habitable zone but just about
every Star has a planet then that planet
if it's got an atmosphere if it's got a
surface that light is going to be
shining down on that planet and how how
much light is in what region of the
spectrum the color of that light is
definitely going to influence how it
interacts with what's on that planet and
and the weather the temperature the
climate of that planet so you have one
of the most complicated problems to
solve out there it seems to me because
it's not just light shine on the planet
it's like how does the chemistry of the
atmosphere interact with the light
that's shining down on the planet does
it get absorbed does it get re-emitted
is it reflected and then if it reaches
the surface then you got to worry about
the surface and and somewhere in there
maybe there's life it's such a really
hard problem it is a really hard problem
because those same those same cool stars
that you know comprise 70 of all stars
in the galaxy those M Stars they're
really awesome because they're so
numerous and there's a lot of advantages
to looking for life around those stars
but there are some disadvantages too
they have really long phases where they
send out a lot of X-ray and UV radiation
shooting towards the surface and we know
the reason why we wear sunscreen is that
UV radiation is not good for biology and
so it could be that you know life could
only exist at the bottom of the ocean on
those planets um it really where you're
protected from the UV
absorber yeah yeah all right okay cool
super cool
all right here we go this is Omar
Marcelino and Omar says hello Dr Tyson
hello Chuck and Dr Shields Omar here
from Dallas Texas Dr Shields given your
unique Journey Through the cosmos of
astronomy and theater two fields that
are often mentioned never in the same
sentence let alone in the same career
you have boldly gone where few have gone
before and leading the way in ensuring
others from diverse backgrounds can do
the same through your work with your
Rising Star girls in your perspective
how could this universe of diverse
talent and experiences Propel us further
into the final frontier how do you think
incorporating a spectrum of perspectives
in astronomy could accelerate our
Interstellar mission to understand and
reach other worlds
whoa now wait a minute is your husband
named Omar
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was an excellently written question
and and uh recited so yeah I'm gonna say
Omar you want to read this book no you
know because this has got the whole
journey in there pretty much everything
you did there yes but what I and go to
risingstargirls.org because you'll
you'll see we're not just teaching these
girls astronomy and astrobiology we're
not just saying hey there's stars out
there there's galaxies these are the
names of it they get to write a poem
about what they're learning they get to
design their own exoplanet and make
choices about how many stars it orbits
and if there's life there and if there's
not why not they get to write their own
constellation myths they get to
calculate the distance from themselves
from the Earth to different solar system
bodies and units of themselves so we're
doing this all to develop a personal
connection between these girls and the
universe of which they're an integral
part so we're processing what they learn
through a creative arts based lens and I
wanted to bring it back to Rising Star
girls because that's really my journey
has
been epitomized by this program of like
it they're not these the Arts and the
Sciences are not as disparate as many
people might think in both cases it's
about the story right everything has a
story
planets Stars they all live right and
they die and there's a story of their
becoming and there's a story of their
evolution and there's a story of their
deaths except planets don't have mother
issues right
certain stories they're not going to
tell I'm pretty sure
the stories the stories are different
but they but there's a journey
or the stories of humans on the stage or
on the screen right looking to live as
as one of my method acting teachers is
to say right trying to find happiness
and fulfillment so there's that whole
like science in the Arts and in fact not
only are they not as disparate as we
might think but they actually
interweaving them is the key in my mind
to answering your question is to
creating imaginative thinkers and
enlightened scientists and enlightened
artists for that matter realizing that
these disciplines can fuel each other
can be used to right to elevate our our
core understanding of The Human
Experience and the right the universal
experience
um so that that would be my nice my best
way to to answer that really exciting
question can I answer that as a minimum
in a day when only men did science it
means half the population of the world
half the intellectual capital of our
species was not at the table at the time
anyone is thinking about how the
universe works so the extent to which
you can extend that to have 100 of our
species have access to whether they
choose it that's another question but if
they don't access to it then you can
ensure that that we're getting the best
Minds who want to actually think about
our past present and future in the
universe yeah and I it's and right now
that is not the case yeah that is
absolutely physically it was half a
percentage-wise it was way more than
that's funny
okay it was half of the mass but and
less than half the actual brain power in
the universe
and we want these girls to claim
ownership of what they're learning you
know to know that that they matter that
they're an integral part of this
universe that you know just in the same
way that if we were to look at the Milky
Way galaxy through one one type of light
just visible light
all right you'd see like this this thin
right this Thin Line
with a bunch of
dark clouds in it and you'd think there
was nothing there if all you looked at
if you look towards the center of the
Milky Way galaxy that swath of space
that some of us can see if we go out in
the desert if you just thought that that
was only
yeah it remaining three percent of the
population of the world yeah that where
there's no extra lights pollution right
if you thought if we thought there was
nothing there we'd miss out on so much
information about this galaxy but if we
looked at the infrared we see so much so
much going on right never mind UV and
Gamma there's so much more right to the
to the Galaxy than meets the eye so too
is there so much more to these girls
than meets the eye and we want them to
to have that that ownership of that star
that planet that Galaxy that they're
studying so that when they continue on
and the heavy math comes in they'd be
less likely to leave the field because
they think oh you know I didn't get that
question right on that test I didn't
know someone told me that you know I
shouldn't be here right just knowing
that they they there's a connection that
they have between what they're learning
and who they are
um that we hope will really help them
stay all right cool all right let's see
if we can slip in two more questions
chuck all right well here's one from
Carrie manaberg and Carrie says hi Dr
Shields is there any scientific evidence
that life on Earth came here from an
interaction with a comet or asteroid
that had biological Foundation chemicals
oh
this is a this is a popular question
within the astrobiology community I
believe that the term for this is
panspermia yes um right that something
comes in from other from elsewhere and
like seeds yeah yeah
um it's I mean
of course it's possible I don't think
it's been given very much
um funding to be honest uh and in terms
of exploration of this topic but it
certainly has been discussed within
astrobiology communities
okay okay all right okay this is Jason
he says uh hello Dr Shields do you have
any personal moral quandaries about
science moving forward or is pretty much
just forget morals and let's just see
how far we can go now I don't know if
Jason is making an indictment of any
sort or not well you know that's a very
specific it's starting out with the
premise that all scientists are immoral
yes basically but I think I think I know
what he means it's like scientists want
to discover what if you and you too Neil
had the opportunity to make a discovery
that would Enlighten but there was a
larger chance that it would destroy
would you still expose that Discovery
that's a moral quandary
hmm
yeah this is an important question
this hearkens back to the last episode
that I was fortunate enough to be on
with you you know where we talked about
terraforming and we talked about some of
the moral and ethical implications of of
that that question of is it okay to
terraform another planet or terraform
Mars
um I do think that as scientists we are
we ethics is must be key so I don't
subscribe to the view that you know
science and Discovery at all costs
um there's a piece that I've written for
uh upcoming a periodical that's um
that's like you know why why do this why
look for life elsewhere why spend
billions of dollars doing all of this
and and is that object that first
Interstellar object you know is that
you know is it really an aliens craft or
is it you know is it just can it be
explained by regular you know regular
scientific
um the scientific method I think what it
comes down to is if we go
and I'm talking about this in the
context of the search for life elsewhere
there's all sorts of other you know
genetics and questions about
cloning and all of that that have their
own ethical implications but I'm from my
part of the sphere on that on that
question
can we if we were to discover that we
are not alone
what would we do with that information
would we
have to go and visit or could we stay on
our planet and know that we're not alone
and let that information inform how we
think and feel and and move throughout
the world
or would we need to go and if we and if
we would need to go and visit
could we just go and visit and then come
back home or would we need to stay and
if we needed to stay
could we just stay and not try to
conquer
or would we have to go the way that that
and emulate what was done on our planet
with Columbus and Magellan and and all
the rest and the implications of that
right that led to genocide
it I would hope that we would be able to
learn from the lessons of the past and
not repeat them and that really is what
I think it all comes back to is is hope
you know I have no clear answer about
what other scientists might do and maybe
even what I might do if given the
opportunity to go to another world and
communicate with other you know other
species but I I carry with me the hope
that I would want to
do whatever we do from a place of Love
kindness inclusivity
and welcome and humility to be honest
so that I think is the key that to be a
scientist I must concede that there is
more
that that that out there that can be
explained and I can hold on to that
humility and help and and allow that to
guide to serve as a North star for me
morally
um so well that that is beautiful
comedian let me just say this that ain't
happening
it's not what is going to happen well
but I got two reactions one I how
Charming it was that you thought we
would go find aliens on another planet
and that we might exploit them it's just
oh rather than like oh yeah Independence
Day and they're gonna come and kill us
yeah yeah
yeah I believe if we go see them they're
not answering the door they're gonna
play the role just like we Jehovah's
Witnesses or something they'll be like
they're here all right don't let them
but we're not get away
from the window I've never had heard
anyone talk about an encounter with
aliens and talk about we exploiting them
that is like never I don't know any
storyline if you're thinking of that
storyline that is completely beautiful
beautiful but of course it mirrors our
what happened on our planet yeah you
know how could I not think of it that
way no you know what I think about it I
think if they come here and they do what
we do to each other oh Lord that's as we
portray in the films then we're creating
them not based on a supposition of how
they would behave but on actual
knowledge of how we did behave
so in fact all of the alien movies are
mirrors to our culture as as you
treating it almost like a a guidebook or
a recipe yeah and I couldn't help
you have to publish a paper
on the interstellar visitor so we have
AO Mawa I know it's so close
we need that research paper I write it I
write in the book I say umua it sounds
like my name oh that's great all my life
studies
Hawaiian and oh my wife does that have
some Origins my parents made it up they
made up yeah vowel sounds they put
together they're musicians they made a
chant up but yeah that sounds I went
down they sounded like hippies they
sound like yeah all the way very nice
well at least you weren't named Moon
Unit okay or sorry or Pilot inspector I
mean come on
that's unfortunate yeah
means messenger from afar arriving first
yes the first first first messenger yes
yeah very cool yeah so guys we gotta end
it there that's sad oh my gosh this is
good this has been fantastic thanks for
being on and congratulations again thank
you so much Neil and thank you Chuck
it's great to be here all right Chuck
good to have you man always a pleasure
all right I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson you're
a personal astrophysicist four-star talk
as always I did you
looking up
[Music]